they caught them that's all hey Lilia
Buckingham we know times have been hard
for you lately but you haven't let that
slow you down you've been doing lots of
really exciting things we're so happy
for you
you've got great friends at Brad and
your career is going strong it's pretty
awesome that you aren't letting your
family's drama affect your acting life
you go girl
and you guys are right Julia's mom got
wrapped up in a huge scandal but Lilia
is still building her career and living
her best life keep watching to find out
about Lilly's latest project and
surprising announcement in March of 2019
a College Admission scandal made
headlines several celebrities were
accused of paying bribes to get their
kids into better colleges are you
surprised I'm not that surprised
lilius mom Jane was one of these people
she paid fifty thousand dollars to help
her son get a good a CT score she worked
with someone to allow a substitute test
taker to sit in for the college
admission test this gave Jack Buckingham
a really high score so he could get into
UCLA but that's cheating and it's super
illegal for Lilia has been having to
deal with her mom's choices ever since
dance friends Lilia got her start as a
competitive dancer she used to dance at
the MNR Dance Factory she never appeared
on Dance Moms herself but she knows a
lot of the dancers who trained with Abby
Lee Miller
she might Mackenzie and Maddie Ziegler
at a dancers meet-and-greet the three
became fast friends they were really
close for a long time beautiful lately
the Ziggler sisters haven't been seen on
Lilly as social media much there's no
evidence of a falling out but it looks
like they might have found other BFFs
chicken girls Lilia wanted to break into
acting and she did it from a pretty
young age she guest-starred on several
well-known shows like Modern Family in
2018 she got a role with the production
company Brad she appeared on the popular
web series chicken girls since then she
has become super famous with fans of
Bratz shows her acting career has really
blossomed
you've got good rhythm baby
good enough to cheer with us frat has
given her lots of opportunities and some
amazing friends Instagram influencer
Lilia is super active on social media as
she now has over 1.6 million followers
on Instagram she posts about her
upcoming projects and about her life she
also makes posts prepping her favorite
companies we love seeing these glimpses
into Lily's life she hasn't posted
anything about her family scandal but
she posts a lot about her adventures
with her friends we love seeing other
celebs pop up on her feed curt but
speaking of being an influencer Lilia is
releasing a book it's called influence
this isn't a book about Lily's life it's
actually a fiction book it's a mystery
about social media influencers blackmail
and murder that sounds amazing Lilia
teamed up with Sara Shepard sara is
known for writing the Pretty Little
Liars books with these two writing it we
know that this novel will be epic and I
can't wait for you guys to read it
influence is set to come out in 2020
that's not Lillias only new project keep
watching to find out about her latest
video brad alter-ego Lilia played autumn
Miller on chicken girls her character
was such a success that she has
continued to play autumn in several
shows her character appeared in dirt and
total eclipse in 2018 and 2019 she was
also one of the main characters in the
longer web movie Spring Break away she
starred alongside in a cop car
annie leblanc and Keanu Naomi this
autumn has also shown up in one episode
of Zooey Valentine which stars in a cap
card we have a feeling that Lily as
character autumn isn't going away
anytime soon
crown Lake Lilia isn't just playing
autumn Miller though she has recently
started playing another character on
Crown Lake Crown Lake follows a girl
named Nelly who goes to a boarding
school
Nelly finds a guide book written by a
past student named Heather Masterson
Lilly has provided the voice of Heather
Masterson I'll give you this
it's of crown-like I wish I'd known
we're super addicted to this new show
Lilia does such an amazing job even
without being on-screen BFFs
we love seeing olive lily as photos with
her squad Lilia has some amazing friends
she's good friends with Milly Bobby
Brown and Anna Cathcart
she's also besties with Emily Skinner
she posts often about how much he loves
Emily in one post she even mentioned
that Emily painted her nails her other
besties are Maitland mezzo Gillian chase
fader and Charlotte block these girls
pop into her posts and stories alive she
even called Maitland her big sister in
one post we're so glad she has such an
awesome crew full of pride in October of
2018 Lilly I made a big announcement she
came out as being into both boys and
girls she made the announcement live on
her Instagram stories the more we
normalized that the better
she has also posted about her pride on
her Twitter during Pride Month this year
we're so happy that Lilia is living her
truth many people including celebrities
don't come out until they're much older
it shows she's really passionate about
being her genuine self even though she's
in the public eye something better
lately Lilia has been working hard on a
new music video she and Jillian chase
Bader have partnered up for this video
but they aren't just starring in it they
wrote it and directed it too that's
really impressive for two teenagers we
had 541 videos we have loved seeing all
of the teasers on lilius social media
the video is called something better and
it came out on September 26 2019 which
of lillius projects are you most excited
about let us know in the comments
section thanks for watching get this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things we'll see you
next time
[Music]